ET has new details about Aaron Carter's
final days as his loved ones and fans
mourn the singer's shocking death yeah I
just um you know my heart goes out to
his family yeah just a lot of love there
Aaron died on Saturday and we've now
learned that the night before he missed
a therapy appointment I love making
music it's definitely my happy place the
LA County Fire Department also confirms
to E.T a welfare check was made for
Aaron on September 20th
since it's child star days Aaron's
personal struggles took over the
spotlight you know the hopes of the
future are this don't come at me the
wrong way because I I will I will fight
to protect my rights and according to
reports he had been working on a show
about recovery titled group what I need
is people to
understand that I'm human and I make
mistakes just like every other human in
this world on Tuesday Aaron's reptiles
E.T quote he was on a path to making
amends with so many people in his life
and among them Nick Carter he's always
been that brother that's been like a
father figure that's been like I'm gonna
push you we're learning Aaron was happy
because he had made peace with his
brother who he loved quote Aaron looked
up to Nick in so many ways they were
trying to make everything good again
Nick did get me started in this and I
thank him for that very much as for
Melanie Martin Aaron's ex-fiancee she
shared this tear-filled moment on tick
tock
the two welcomed the sun last year
in a statement to ET she says quote I
haven't slept since it happened I don't
think I will be okay I'm in complete
shock and denial it's just you know I
went through some hard times some
difficult things at home Aaron was
usually surrounded by friends but things
looked a little different before he died
to be honest when I got there
the day the incident happened
there was no friends over there
I was really surprised it was just me
and Melanie and Melanie families you
know a few people but people I used to
see him every day in his house on his
face time nobody was there
that's why it's kind of concerning me
what happened the 34 year old's body was
discovered in a bathtub at his home but
there is no official cause of death
known at this time as we wait for more
details his peers are paying tribute uh
sending our love out to the family
definitely crossed circles multiple
times Within the Music Industry and
obviously the industry my heart goes out
to Nick
um
such a tragedy and I think we really do
need to get the world in order so that
we can start focusing on Mental Health
it's a real thing we need to stop losing
our youth to it it's a true tragedy
because he was just a very innocent to
me he's like an innocent young child and
I felt like on Dancing With the Stars he
had this moment where people could see
him in his fullest sense he was I'll
always remember that about him
foreign